covert 19 has meant a harrowing 13
months for the state-run national health
service
it's placed extraordinary stress and
emotional strain on the system and those
who work in it
and a 2.1 pay rise had been promised and
expected
now the government says it can only
afford a one percent increase
so this year has been a really tough
year for us
for intensive care nurses such as becky
smith that's insulting
and demoralizing feeling valued helps us
to look after our patients better it
helps us to put more into our jobs it
helps us to
appreciate to educate each other to
mentor each other to work stronger
together because we feel happier at work
we feel
valued at work we feel that the work
that we're doing is important
but to not be valued by you know the
government and
in some cases the public is really
difficult and it is really challenging
and it does make you want to give up
the actual pay offer will be decided by
an independent pay review body
but the government's stance saw boris
johnson come under sustained attack
at the weekly session of prime
minister's questions two years ago
he made a promise to the nhs here in
black and white his document
it commits to a minimum pay rise of 2.1
percent
it's thanks to the investment made by
this government that there are 49
000 more people in the nhs this year
than last year
10 600 more nurses helping
to relieve the burden on our
hard-pressed nurses the current
three-year nhs pay deal finishes
at the end of this month but the pay
review body isn't due to submit its
recommendations until may
and that means it could be the summer
before staff find out whether they're
going to get the rise that they want
and that many people feel they deserve
the unions say their members have seen
their pay cut
by between seven percent and twenty
percent in the past decade
in real terms and enough is enough none
of us want to take industrial action
lightly but we are adamant we won't let
this government put patient
safety at risk by undermining our
profession
just as just months after they invited
the press onto their doorsteps to watch
them clap for us
there's been a really really um huge
mental health burden on nhs staff
because of everything they've gone
through
and then after all that to be told that
all of that effort all of that skill and
complexity and organization they've
shown
to be offered you know one percent which
amounts to a real terms pay cut
is a is very very insulting and it's
understandable many of them feel so
angry about it
for 13 months frontline nhs staff were
described deservedly as heroes
and the public applauded them in the
streets but with an end to the pandemic
seemingly in sight the question of how
to reward that heroism hasn't yet been
answered
paul brennan al jazeera london